Rolling Stone put out an article uh it
was something like NBA's anti-vaxxer
problem and they're pushing around the
league and all that stuff and I had a
call with a journalist and it was all
good faith oh you know Jonathan you know
would love to get your story all this
stuff and I'm telling them about you
know what my decision not to get
vaccinated and then the article comes
out and it's like Jonathan Isaac waited
for people to die he put his trust in
God all this different stuff I'm like
this is terrible and I was Furious
because this is the first time that I
had saw that there there is a media bias
and a uh you know people call it
propaganda people call it um you know
they if they want something to go in a
certain way they have the power and the
tools to do so yeah um and you know to
their discretion and so that was my
first instance of being like they're
right people are telling the truth about
all this stuff
I'm Dave Rubin we're here at locals in
Miami and joining me is a forward for
the Orlando Magic author of the book why
I stand and founder of the new clothing
company unite us Jonathan Isaac welcome
back to the Reuben report thank you for
having me man glad to be here I have to
say you're the first person we ever had
to move a table for and actually change
some of the situation that we have going
here people want to know most
importantly 610 611 611 really really
like seven some with the hair but
does the hair count on rebounding it
doesn't it does not uh it's good to see
you again we've done a couple sit-downs
over the years uh obviously NBA player
author as I said launching a new brand
uh just quick for the people that that
don't know you give me a little of the
the Jonathan Isaac story getting you to
the NBA and then we'll get into the new
stuff of getting to the NBA yeah give me
the the life story that gets you to the
NBA and then we'll get to what you're
doing super quick I'd like to say the
name Jonathan Isaac I grew up in Bronx
New York until I was about 10. played a
little bit of basketball people there
but not it wasn't like my thing moved to
Naples Florida started to play a little
bit of organized basketball
um fell in love with it kind of put
everything into it became the number one
player in the State of Florida
went to Florida State University I went
to IMG for a year before that IMG
Academy Florida State University and
then was drafted to expect to the uh
Orlando Magic back in 2017. and so now
you've been in the NBA that's what six
seasons uh couple injuries but you're
you're healthy now you finish the season
I'm ready to rock you're ready to rock
so this will be really like your first
season in a couple years this upcoming
First full season yes I got to play a
little bit this this past season coming
back you know it was a big deal um we're
missing a lot of time but uh this is my
first summer of being actually able to
work out and not just be rehabbing so it
feels good to actually get in the gym
and work out and and looking forward to
this upcoming season how does it feel to
be out as long as you were out in the
ups and downs of surgery and all that
stuff and you know I have a I have a
torn ACL right now so out of four knees
here you you have the two good ones
ironically
um at least mostly good I guess
um but like just mentally to like get
back on the court after all that time
and everything how does that feel it's
tough it's tough It's a uh it's terrible
honestly like like
going through it you know you have it's
not just like you going through an
injury kind of by yourself you have
you're dealing with it you have the fans
are dealing with it yeah the the
organization is dealing with it you know
fans when are you going to come back and
play why aren't you playing
um so it's not something that's easy to
do
um and I know for a fact that I wouldn't
be able to kind of press my way through
it if it wasn't for one my faith
um and then the people that I have
around me my wife my family my pastor my
church family
um people to just encouraged me and help
me to see the good in every single
situation that I'm going through
um and that has me here and also you
know I think the last point of that is
just being able to identify with other
people who get injured now I I have a I
have a new I guess like perspective on
injury and and how much grit and grind
it takes and how you do get to see who
you are when you're faced with that kind
of diversity as an athlete what about
the mental part when you get back on the
court like your doc says okay your knees
fine and you're like your body feels
good but because I can tell you man I'm
no NBA player but just from playing with
a Weak Knee like it's more mental that
I'm always worried about when I'm
running around out there than the
physical part in a way honestly it's
like riding a bike
um I I have heard that it's it's very
tough for certain guys you know when you
get back just kind of trusting it
um for me that really wasn't much just
stress the doubt yeah well not the doc I
just trust that I'm ready to go yeah my
trust is in God and so I'm just like
look I'm Healed they say I'm clear I'm
ready to rock and I just kind of put one
foot in front of the other and once you
get that uh regular the training wheels
once you get like okay I jumped I fell
and nothing happened you kind of just
forget about it but I do know that for
some for some people it is very
difficult to get back on the court after
a big injury like that so the thing that
kind of put you on the map during covid
and and all of the the BLM stuff and all
that uh you stood for the national
anthem which was not that popular at the
time at all when you look back on that
do you think it was like well I have no
doubt that you you're you're proud of
what you did but does it seem like a
crazy time to look back on that the
bubble with the NBA just the whole
situation insane
um it's weird like because now like kind
of the Dust is settled
um you know things have come out about
BLM and the organization the way that
they handle funds and stuff like that so
it's just like
it doesn't it's not as as kind of potent
right now but when you go back in time
like even covet stuff it's it's died
down people aren't as emotional about it
but In the Heat of it it was like it was
like Armageddon it was it was it was it
was real
um so to be in that moment of deciding
on what I was going to do I was going to
handle the pressure of the moment uh it
really was it really really really
really really was tough so then you you
do that and then kind of you get
welcomed by like a whole bunch of people
that maybe politically you probably
thought maybe either weren't your people
or it was just like a community of
people you publish your book with the
daily wire right like these were
probably not things you would have
expected can you talk about like what it
was like to kind of go in that direction
so to speak yeah I mean so after I got
after I decided to stand in a bubble um
and go through that entire process there
was were you literally the only player
that did no one of the player did I
believe miles Myers Leonard
um he's not even in the league anymore
no he's not in the league anymore that
that's interesting there were some other
stuff there but like yes he's young
enough and skilled enough right no I'm
pretty sure you can definitely play yeah
um but yeah so there was a ton of you
know negativity around this thing
obviously people were upset um about me
deciding to stand and not kneel um but
then you talked about the there was an
overwhelming support
um obviously of Christians people who
understood you know the heartbeat of why
I decided to stand in the first place
um I did I never felt comfortable with
the tone and the rhetoric of the black
lives matter organization and I didn't
want to co-sign their message by putting
on their t-shirt
um and also I didn't want to co-sign you
know their message by kneeling and so
there was that kind of you know
conservative folks that uh obviously see
this kind of person standing up for the
flag and they kind of latched on to it
but I tried my best to stay true to my
message of I believe that if we decide
all of us white black and different
truths to love each other like God loves
us which is in spite of our sin instead
of our shortcomings and realizing that
we all fall short of God's glory we
could have real progress and change and
so that's what I stuck to but I I I
wasn't uh I wasn't negative towards that
kind of attention you know they
definitely welcomed me with open arms
and being able to publish a book with
the daily wire I started to learn about
these people and and and you know they
show me love they showed me love so
they're not a bunch of crazy racists no
that's that's not what I got from it you
know I would get questions about like
you know why would you publish your book
with the daily Wire yeah they're all
racist and I'm like well you know why
would they publish my book you know
obviously there is there's an
ideological
um
similarity that Trump's skin color
um in their eyes or they wouldn't
publish my book they would be like okay
we might agree with him on some things
but he's black you know right right so
obviously that Trump that color my skin
and and even with Ben Shapiro being you
know you know an orthodox Jew and me
being a Christian
um still decided to publish my book and
my book is like all about Jesus at the
end of the day and you're 6 11 and he's
like four too so that there's a huge
discrepancy very intimidating and so uh
so yeah so no it was it was a great
process
um very tough like I said you know there
was there was one moment and you know I
tried my best to spell this all out in
the book but I was on the phone with my
pastor the night before I decided to
stand and I'm telling him like I don't
think you understand how crazy this is
going to be I hadn't signed my contract
yet I was up for an extension that that
summer
um I knew I was going to be name called
I knew I was going to be ridiculed for
it and he said to me you cannot stand
for God and God not stand for you and so
that was kind of like the mic drop
moment I was like all right I'm doing it
and we went full you know Full Speed
Ahead yeah and it's basically uh it's
basically work since then you're doing a
lot of stuff including including you got
a new three-month-old in your life too
yes um even talking about doing stuff I
never in a million years would have
thought that I'd be an author so even
when I get introduced like that Jonathan
all three NBA player I'm like why this
still doesn't make any sense to me but
to be an author to have that come out of
um this moment of standing it is really
surreal and now I got a baby girl yeah
how's fatherhood treating you I love it
it's it's like you know there's not many
words for it or to try to put it into
its right perspective but it is that
unconditional love for something that
that you know you're responsible for and
so it's been it's been it's been amazing
yeah so all of this stuff happens uh you
get some of the pushback now seeing some
of the Dust settle the guys come up to
you now and they're like hey you know
maybe I should have done that or I
respect what you did or is there any of
that kind of stuff or is everyone yeah
I've had I've had plenty of
conversations
um not just for the bmm stuff but I I
would say even more so for the cover
like that yeah so it is something and
that people forget but like even that
moment was like I'm the only player on
my team and one of a handful of guys in
the NBA that decided not to get
vaccinated and so that was we'll throw
to a video of that right here so that
people people can see it again
um I'm not anti-vaxx I'm not
anti-medicine I'm not anti uh science I
didn't come to my current vaccination
status by studying black history or
watching Donald Trump press conferences
I have nothing but the utmost respect
for every Health Care
um worker and person in Orlando and all
across the world that have worked
tirelessly to keep us safe my mom has
worked in healthcare for a really long
time
um I thank God I'm grateful that I live
in a society where vaccines are possible
and kind of uh protect ourselves and
have the means to protect ourselves for
the first in the first place
um but with that being said it is my
belief that the the vaccine status of
every person should be their own choice
um and completely up to them without the
without bullying without being pressured
without being forced into doing so I'm
not ashamed to say that I'm
uncomfortable with taking the vaccine at
this time I think that we're all
different we all come from different
places we've all had different
experiences and hold dear to different
beliefs and uh what it is that you do
with your body when it comes to putting
medicine in there should be your choice
I'm free of the ridicule and the opinion
of others but was that completely on the
Fly for you or I mean I guess everyone
was asked being asked questions like
that but were you planning on that
moment so what happened this is what
happened what happened was not to take
up too much time on this topic but what
happened was
um I had gone through the whole thing I
saw everything that was going out you
know people were being crazy about covid
um all these weird things about why you
should get a shot God and incentivizing
you to get a shot I'm like and then
obviously you're getting bullied if you
even have any questions about it natural
immunity all that stuff you didn't want
to do it for the free hamburger I'm like
yo if you're trying to get somebody to
do something threatening them isn't it
it's only going to make them more weary
I'm like I don't know what's going on
but I decided not to do it
um and then Rolling Stone put out an
article uh it was something like NBA's
anti-vaxxer problem and they're pushing
around the league and all that stuff and
I had a call with a journalist and it
was all good faith oh you know Jonathan
you know would love to get your story
all this stuff and I'm telling them
about you know what my decision not to
get vaccinated and then the article
comes out and it's like Jonathan Isaac
waited for people to die he put his
trust in God all this different stuff
I'm like this is terrible and I was
Furious because this is the first time
that I had saw that there there is a
media bias and a uh you know people call
it propaganda people call it um you know
they if they want something to go in a
certain way they have the power and the
tools to do so yeah and you know to
their discretion and so that was my
first instance of being like they're
right people are telling the truth about
all this stuff and so uh once you see
that isn't it freaky because yes because
no matter how you see it no matter what
leads you to that moment of seeing it
once you see it you can't unsee it it's
freaky but it's friend too yeah because
now I'm like okay it's like I have my
moment of like okay I I know what all
this means and so I Was preparing myself
um because I had media day coming up
literally the next day after the article
dropped so I knew I was going to get
questions people were tweeting me
telling me I'm crazy and stupid and all
this stuff and I'm an anti-backer and so
uh I took that kind of that night to be
like okay I know what it is that I stand
for I know why I did what I did and not
taking it and kind of just prepare
myself and then I got the questions yeah
so you the covet thing the BLM thing the
injury thing
all of this stuff fatherhood then you
get back on the court just for the end
of the season I mean that's like a lot
of stuff that you're that you kind of oh
you release a book I mean like a whole
speaking gigs all that stuff uh just to
get you to just to what you love and
what your your main gig is it's pretty
amazing I just I mean I just stay busy
like you know I was I was rehabbing
every day I was putting in the work
um but you know I had free time on my
hands to to do and to think and create
and you know just try my best to be an
inspiration to other people who also
found themselves in this moment but
didn't have either the courage or the
the people around them to stand and
that's something that it wasn't on me I
had people around me pushing me to to be
a a light to other people and so that's
that's why a lot of the stuff that I did
I decided to do it do you think you were
proven right not only on the covid stuff
but even on a lot of the woke stuff uh
and then this will sort of get us to
United but like you know the NBA even
has scaled back on the on the woke stuff
you know they they had the BLM logos on
the on the court they basically those
are gone they seem like they've shifted
out of it
um the NHL for example they're not going
to do Pride night anymore like just
these things that they push on everybody
it does seem like there's been some
reversal or something yeah a thousand
percent thousand percent there is
um I think that uh
it's just when you get to these moments
of hostility and everything is at their
rise it is very easy to jump on you know
we want to support this and we want to
push this but when the dust does settle
and kind of everybody kind of comes back
to their senses and like okay what is
going on where are things at
um I do think that the kind of rational
thing to do is to scale back
um and kind of get back to program as
usual yeah and that's what a lot of
people and companies have done I'm
guessing most of the players probably
feel that way too privately right like
that they're just like I just want to
play ball like I think I think that's a
lot I think even past players I think
that's just most Americans yeah um
especially when it comes to sports and
entertainment they do just want to enjoy
and I'm not saying that uh
I'm not saying that the free choice for
companies to voice their opinion on
issues that they feel strongly about is
wrong
um I think that that's the great thing
about America people are free to do so
um but I do think that in sport and
entertainment there should be discretion
and there should be Nuance
um that the people that are watching are
not all the same they don't all believe
the same things and they should you know
that should go into your messaging and
what you decide to put out there and not
demonizing one set of people or one
group or one side
um but just you know trying to share you
know your view as a company and as a
person and I think at the same time if
the league is comfortable doing it they
should then be just as comfortable
allowing their athletes to do it too
even if it's in a way that they don't
agree with right that seems to be the
the part that the leagues never get on
board with right the two-way street
portion of this thing yeah so uh you
mentioned Naples now you play for
Orlando Florida guy uh according to the
to the media that you no longer trust I
thought Florida is no good for black
people
isn't that what they tell us I mean I've
been okay here for for a while and uh
and you're not hiding you're not hiding
at six eleven yeah no I mean look it's
just you know no no place is perfect
um every place has their ups and their
downs but to a spouse that you know
black people can't be in Florida it is
it is ridiculous
um and that's that kind of the Nuance
that people don't you know everything is
just so polarizing these days you get
you get the hits and you get the the
controversy that likes by saying
something extremely controversial and
then it goes everywhere or this one one
side is saying oh I can't believe they
said that and the other side is trying
to back what the person said
um but obviously that's false with the
amount of African-Americans that live in
Florida you know what the number one
state for black owned small businesses
is it Florida
there you go it is there you go so
speaking of business uh you're starting
Unitus which now is going to be
basically well you tell me I I don't
want to put words in your mouth I was
going to say something you tell me what
it's going to be so um back in 2020 same
kind around that time of the BLM and the
covet I was a Nike signed athlete and
paid by Nike signed by Nike
um and after I got injured I ended up
how does that process go by the way when
they're when you're drafted they're
bringing in to all the shoe companies
come up to you and everybody's trying to
figure out who to go to who are you yeah
it depends largely on
um who you were as a college athlete as
well and so I've worn Nike kind of my
whole life once I got into basketball so
I was on I was in the eybl which is
Nike's kind of youth AAU circuit so I
was always I was always wearing Nike
then loved it
um when I got to Florida state Florida
State so Nike school
um got to the league uh well we're
transitioning into the league I was
quoted by Adidas
um for a while but no other companies I
was kind of adamant about you know I
want to be a Nike Guy and um ended up
signing with them and it was it was
great like I I love Nike
um and I have loved Nike for a long time
I disagree
um with them and a lot of other
companies have kind of made conscious
decisions over the last few years to
move in a in a specific Direction This
is what they're saying that they're for
um and when it comes to United for me
it's just about Freedom it's just about
look these companies are allowed to do
it just like I talked about the
organizations like the NBA but we're
also free to support what we want to
support
and if I could create something that
stands up for Family Faith Freedom
um and the values and ideas that one has
made this country great
um has made this country process prosper
and have the progress that it has had
from its founding
um and then just stay true to who I am
as a Christian man and athlete and and
person uh I want those values to be
celebrated in the marketplace and in the
culture and what better what what a
better way to do that than through
really cool awesome clothing yeah so
it's an athletic wear brand that
athletic wear and Leisure wear and
Leisure wear so we'll show some images
while we're talking right now how does
this even begin how does this happen
that like so one day did you have the
idea and then you go to somebody did
somebody no no you yeah I'll tell you so
um my pastor is a huge part of my life
um you know I was like I told you I was
on the phone with him the night before I
decided to stand in the bubble but um
just talking to him and he he was the
reason why I wrote the book as well he
comes rushing over to my house one day
and says people know your stand but they
don't know your story
and that was the thing of saying you
need to write a book and you need to do
a movie all this different stuff uh is
the movie coming we've been we've been
in talks for quite a while but if
anybody wants to do the last day movie
hit me up all right uh but yeah so uh
after I didn't resign with Nike
um talking to him he says you know you
should you should look into creating
your own shoe you know something that
you know stands for your values and that
you can use for you it wasn't
necessarily something that could be you
know broadcasters to everybody
um and I said you know I don't think you
understand how hard it is to create a
like this isn't this isn't easy and
I've learned how difficult it is to
create a high you know high value high
performance shoe
um but to his guidance I kind of said
I'll set out and see what it looks like
had some conversations and then was like
I'm gonna do it and uh that vision of
just creating a shoe for myself to wear
during the season turned into there are
so many people that believe like I
believe and as I see the decline of
these values and ideals that I believe
deserve to be celebrated as I see their
decline in the marketplace and culture
um why not give these people uh
something for them give them a home
build a community of people that are
saying
um these we love these values and we
stand on these values and I think too
with being the only person to do a
couple of things I do know how lonely it
is to do something by yourself and I
knew that the fear aspect and the
intimidation aspect of everything that's
going on around you is very daunting and
so if I can help people
have a sense of Pride about their values
and ideals
um and be able to wear it on their
sleeve I think that's something that's
beautiful and an American and free and
so uh
that Vision started to kind of bounce
around my head and uh he came up with
the name Unitus and we were just kind of
like playing with it and and from there
we kind of I've just been kind of
executing the background not saying
anything to anybody so what do you do
like you was the first idea okay I'm
gonna create the shoe first yeah there's
the shoe started first so I'm I am going
to be debuting a shoe at some point this
Summer that I will be wearing this
upcoming season it's called the Judo one
I'm gonna be five colorways each
colorway has a different verse um Bible
verse that goes with the the colorway in
the shoe um but that's just that's
that's not necessarily United's just yet
um one of the things about Unitus is I
want to be able to sign athletes from
all different sports as we grow
um value aligned athletes to be you know
ambassadors and forerunners for the
company and brand I'm going to be the
first signed athlete to the company and
so that sneaker is gonna fall under
Judah that is signed to unite us and so
um it started there and then it looked
like okay when were you there like at
the factory like just telling them this
is what I want I want this weight I want
I'll tell you this yeah there's a
company called Soul Works they're
ex-nikey guys ex Adidas guys that have
kind of come together and said you know
we want to do one-off shoes for certain
people so they're doing they're doing
mushroom then it's just cleat they're
doing you know I think they did a shoe
for Pharrell or something like that as
well and so I got hooked up with them
and I said you know I don't know
anything about this field or this
industry and they did so we kind of
linked up and were able to come into
some type of partnership and the shoes
being made out of Vietnam and so they've
been you know going back and forth and
sending me videos and photos and the
design process took forever
um but it took up you know pretty much
an entire year to be able to get a this
is what we want the shoe to look like
this is what we wanted to to feel like
to have the prototypes all that stuff
and now we're here right right are you
involved in making sure that the process
yeah being made in Vietnam all that
stuff you know obviously Nike gets a lot
of flack for some of their practices
like how about a thousand percent they
they they've assured me they've gone
back and forth that this is an
upstanding Factory I was very adamant
about
um not Desiring too many manufacturer in
China and trying to find you know
sourcing otherwise and we were able to
so I'm happy about that that must have
been complex because I feel like
everything's made out of China
everything is made out of China but um
for clothing and stuff there's there's
great factories in turkey and a lot of
the embroidering and stitching is done
right here in America yeah so okay so
you launch with the shoe and then over
the fall then a bunch of the other so on
August 1st people will be able to buy
Leisure wear yeah and so that's going to
be t-shirts hoodies sweatpants
um jackets stuff like that and then as
we move through the fall there's going
to be uh a sportswear drop for men and
women there's also kids that's going to
be available in the Leisure wear as well
and as we get closer to the season we'll
drop the sneaker and then you know the
hope is that we'll be able to build on
this and you know training shoes running
shoes walk around shoes everything like
that and kind of off into the sunset do
you view your your basketball career in
some way as just the vehicle that then
became the thing to do all of this other
stuff I mean not only the company but
spiritual stuff and everything else I
would say to a degree
um I love basketball
um I love playing it I love the game
ever since I was a kid
um but I it has become
what I do and not who I am
um I found my identity in Christ and I
just try my best to use that as a
platform for who I am and uh I love the
game I can't wait to get back to it
um I'm I'm getting ready to have a great
season I'm looking forward to it but
again I I try to use it as a vehicle to
portray you know who I am as an
individual over you know basketball
being the end-all be held it down to
Jonathan Isaac do you get any pushback
on the controversial stuff because
sometimes I find people after you've
been through it enough that you've hit
you've hit big ones right flag like
America or like you've hit not just
minor ones like big ones but sometimes
you get to the other side and then
there's a certain type of person just
completely moves on and another type of
person kind of stays in the in that
craziness for a while well I definitely
still get it
um I think that my skin has gotten a bit
thicker
um where it's just like yo like I know
who I am and you know I'm gonna let you
know who I am and what it is that I
believe in and you're free to like that
or not but I'm going to be authentic to
myself and so uh I definitely still get
pushed back like you know I can't I
can't tweet something without getting a
Tweet back about what somebody thinks
about me which just fine yeah but um but
yeah I definitely you know going through
the course and kind of going through the
ringer of what does it look like to be
attacked and have your name kind of drug
through the mud
um and it does make you a stronger more
resilient person again I'm just thinking
of this on the fly but you know another
guy who has said a lot of controversial
things another one that's no longer in
the league is enes Kanter yeah who
certainly skill wise guy was averaging a
double double I think his last season I
mean he should be in the league so that
must have been sitting with you for a
lot of this too right well yeah I even
with you know back during BLM I told you
I hadn't signed my contract yet so I
already knew that this could be
something that you know derails that
because of you know you never know about
you know possibility of being
blackballed from the NBA
um that there's a chance of that
happening
um or you know your organization or
somebody head up that high up that you
don't even know says you know we don't
want that guy on our team anymore
um I'm sure it has happened behind
closed doors and we don't know about it
but uh you know even possibly in that in
this situation don't know what
transpired for him not to be in the
league anymore but it was definitely a
thought in the back of my mind that this
could be the end of my career but just
kind of piggybacking on what you know my
pastor told me you can't stand for God
and God not stand for you I stood I was
able to sign my contract and you know
keep moving forward the magic yeah so
you must have a real love for the
Orlando organization I would imagine I
I've got I've got major because most
most wouldn't have I mean I think that's
pretty good I've got major respect
um you know I was their first draft pick
the new uh
John Hammond and Jeff wiltman I was
their first pick and so they've done
right by me they show me love
um even through all the controversial
stuff and so I definitely have a good
respect for him yeah
what else is next well I guess the
movie's next okay you're working on
you're working on the movie I feel like
we're gonna do this every year and every
year right we have another major another
major project what's next is just you
know having a great season and seeing
um seeing United's take off
um you know hoping that people obviously
love what it looks like that's a huge
thing I wanted it to be something that's
culturally relevant and that young
people adults kids they want to wear it
obviously that's great
um but even more so I want to see the
message of
believing and finding pride and
encouragement in our values I want to
see that propagated I want to see that
grow
um whoever what vehicle that is I
believe that United is a vehicle that
that can stand the test of time and have
people feel that way about the brand in
the company and that's all I'm looking
for do you have certain athletes in in
different sports that you're talking to
or you kind of have your eye on them I'm
the type of guy yeah I've got a few okay
I've had some great conversations with
different guys I won't name them
um I think by the time this comes out
people already know but uh Riley Gaines
is going to be our first brand
ambassador awesome so she'll be at the
end as well
um she's not swimming anymore but she's
a she's a she's a firehouse
um for what she's stood for and been
able to do in women's sports and looking
forward to seeing her kind of career and
speaking and everything like that take
off and so she's awesome yeah it never
stops they'll always find another one
for you right like there's just always
another controversy and another guy
that'll hopefully do the right thing yes
yeah how involved are you in not just
the shoes which you talked about but all
the the clothing athletic wear Etc in
terms of design and all that like I'm
super involved to keep it as well I'm
I'm super involved yeah um it's
definitely something that I try to get
knocked out of my in my free time yeah
um meetings and calls and stuff like
that but I'm I'm healthily involved to
where I can still do what I got to do
but also steer this thing in a way that
sticks to the vision that I set out for
it to be
I don't say this to many guests but
you're basically living my dream you're
you're in the NBA and you're doing a
zillion other things I know you love the
Hoops so I appreciate that you love all
right next time next time we're doing
this at my house so we can get that
one-on-one game going okay but again
wait how old are you 25. so I'm I'm 47
so you got 22 years on me you got
about a foot and a half and and you got
two good knees it's not really fair you
won't score can you you play NBA Live
can we try that maybe no actually I'm
actually not very good at that stuff but
you'll probably be doing that for sure
if I could get an H on you that would be
enough okay a Horton a horse you're
probably good at horse though I can
shoot I can shoot something okay that's
the last thing to go yeah all right
we'll see we'll see then
appreciate you
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell